jared goff has no such worries in
detroit because among other things the
lions have not drafted a potential
long-term quarterback they had that
seventh overall pick they created enough
of a sense that maybe they were looking
at quarterback to get people to wonder
would they take a quarterback at seven
jared goff the guy for the foreseeable
future here's goff meeting with
reporters yesterday talking about his
pleasure over the fact that the lions
did not take a quarterback in the draft
yeah we had some talks uh before the
draft and um
i i again i think it's a nice photo of
confidence obviously for me and um
i think what's not lost on me is is that
their first move as
as a staff with brad and dan was
involved me so i it's exciting and it
makes you feel good
just bizarre
to say lions quarterback jared goff
another example of how dramatically the
nfl can change in any one offseason and
the lions have cast a lot with this guy
they took on a big contract they picked
up a couple of first-round picks and a
third round pick and uh bye-bye matthew
stafford who was a very very good
quarterback and now goff gets to come in
as part of this new culture you know
it's possible
even though i think stafford is a much
better quarterback passer everything you
could ask for in a quarterback than goff
all due respect to goff the team could
have more success with goff because
maybe this time after
60 years of swinging and missing they've
finally put together the mindset that's
necessary for the lions to be a winning
organization
look you know i noticed this over the
weekend when you see the the lions all
fired up in their draft room with new gm
brad holmes new coach
um
you know they're they're scouts they're
everybody is in there so excited
after they make that penne sewell pick
but i guess the point i would make is
sometimes those things are really really
important because you have to really
want
you
part of being good is you have to really
want to be good and i sit back at some
of the lions regimes and watch in the
last few years
and you have to ask yourself about like
matt patricia you know you wonder you
really really wonder about matt patricia
and whether by the time last year where
he became a little bit more touchy-feely
you have to wonder if the players had
just tuned them out and i think many of
them had they had to get rid of darius
slay because of that
i think dan campbell's whole idea is we
are going to own this
like look at this
you know to me i i just think that is a
really cool example of how happy
and how good they feel
after taking a guy they know it could be
transformative for their franchise
you know it's funny peter we had brad
holmes on the show yesterday and i asked
him right out of the gates is the
explanation for that moment that you
guys had asked for decaf coffee and they
accidentally brought in caffeinated
but he said no that
it was
pure raw emotion of the moment and it
was great we had fun with brad holmes
yesterday we'll have the video posted at
pft uh but yeah the rams
gave up on goff
the lion's given him a chance with all
these cultural changes they're making
and at some point if you're the lions at
some point aren't you gonna stumble into
something that works after all these
iterations and attempts and failed
regimes just the law of averages peter
at some point
it's just gonna happen despite
whatever flaws you may have in putting a
team together you're gonna accidentally
put together the right mixture and
wherever that colonel came from to do
what they're doing with chris spielman
and i really do think he's a big piece
of this
bigger than we realize but but uh this
old school mentality the kneecap fighter
stuff we've had fun with that phrase but
it's a mentality that a lot of teams
don't have nowadays
and when there's a small handful of
teams like that
it's jarring to the other teams when
they come up against it
and you know look where we're really
gonna be able to tell mike uh about sort
of the color and the verve and the
passion of this program we're gonna be
able to tell during this season and okay
so they play the season whatever happens
happens
but during this season what's going to
happen is that other players around the
league are going to look at the detroit
lions and you look at what penne sewell
said in his press conference and he
basically said hey listen we got life in
the d or whatever his his cool quote was
but
that is what
other players could be drawn to
let's say the lions go nine and eight
they barely miss the playoffs but
they're on the rise a little bit go
golf plays well
and then in the off season
x free agent and y free agent and z free
agents say to their agent hey listen
let's talk to the lions if they have any
interest at all that's the kind of stuff
you want to get players who want to play
for your franchise
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports